foreign
in San Francisco what's up Sarah Sarah
how are you doing today so good how are
you
I'm good what's up okay so my my
question is I went straight to culinary
school from high school cool in 2003.
thank you
um my mom took out a loan for me because
I was 17. okay uh the original loan was
30 000. we agreed to split it 50 50.
um soon as I graduated I was giving her
money every month I was staying with her
because I didn't have the money but I
was giving her money every month I
eventually realized that she was not
paying on the student loan at all
um when I found out she apologized and
she said that she was she would start
paying I continued to give her money
every month um as you can imagine I
wasn't making very much money at that
time
um and I I then again discovered she was
not applying any of that much support
the the student loans
um how much have you given her so far
yeah
I'm not sure exactly because I wasn't
counting but I do know that I gave her
when when we talked I I gave her at
least five thousand okay how did how did
you give it was it a check how did you
do that I was given her cash I was
giving her two hundred dollars
oh man every month well I was making I
was making minimum wage I was working
yeah yeah yeah at um anyway is your is
your name on the loan or your mom's yeah
your mom's name is on the loan only my
mom it's a Parent PLUS Loan so the
reason why I know now all this
information is because recently she came
to me and she brought up this loan
because after a while I just stopped
giving her money how long has it been so
2003 oh girl okay so recently she
brought up this loan and she asked me
for a lump sum of money she asked me for
about twenty thousand dollars I'm like I
don't have that kind of money I can't
give you that and we didn't agree I've
been giving you money blah blah long
story short I looked into the loan she
owes over seventy thousand dollars okay
okay oh God Sarah listen Lord this is
um oh gosh I'm sorry I had to let a
little bit of my I had to let it out a
little bit sorry and I don't know what
to do here's what's here's what's not
scary about it yeah okay
there is some scary but it's not I don't
think it's what you think it is okay
here's the scary
um
your you and your mom's relationship is
different from this point forward
okay okay and the sooner you come to
terms with the fact that your mother
um
did not uphold your end of the agreement
I can tell you all day I think the
agreement was Dumb and y'all should
never have set that up um it was it was
destined to create a wedge between a
mother and a daughter but here we are
um
she has decided to not
um sit down and be the adult and say I
took out a loan here's every month for
the next however many years here's what
you're going to pay me here's how this
is going to work I'm going to keep a
spreadsheet I'm going to mark off every
date all that like a bank would do yeah
it you basically funded her lifestyle in
a tiny little way and then she comes
knocking on your door 20 years later
asking for twenty thousand dollars yeah
do you know who's not on the hook for
the
you are not on the hook for this money
now this is your mom and I know that you
feel some level of guilt or but I should
probably but you you gave her the money
you gave it to her retired that doesn't
it doesn't matter at this literally at
this point anything you say about to try
to like make it better I'm gonna tell
you it doesn't matter you gave her the
money she chose
she chose
and now for whatever reasons that she
has which don't matter she wants that
money back from you well the loan is
probably is it tripled is it true is it
80 or 90 000 70 000 it's 70 000 and some
change and now she's making me feel like
here's what you know here's what you
could do she doesn't hold on she doesn't
get to
you're allowing her to get inside you
and to make you feel a certain way you
decide who has permission to hurt you
period now that's harder when it's our
mom because our mom should be the one
person on the planet that's always got
our side and yours doesn't
okay and I I hate that for you but she's
not making you feel bad you're choosing
to feel bad on her behalf
okay you gotta own that
you gotta own that okay here's what you
could do now you said to your you said
if you were really interested in feeling
very clean walking away from this
situation you said that the loan was
thirty thousand and you were supposed to
split it so that would be 15K on you now
if you're telling me hey I paid 5 000
towards this loan I know that I paid
five thousand give her another 10K and
say hey
I paid my half and that would have been
it if you wanted to do that and just say
I know I paid 15 you didn't do your
thing whatever you could do that
um but you're not on the hook for this
all right so Sarah Sarah if I'm in if
this is me like I'm just I'm fast I'm
thinking about this being my mom okay
and we sit down what I would say is
exactly what Jade said but I would I
would I would add one extra layer I
would put a payment plan in front of her
yeah and say I agreed to pay fifteen
thousand dollars of a thirty thousand
dollar loan uh I'm gonna pay you 20 back
and I'm gonna already say I've already
given you five and that's on the low end
so I'm gonna pay you fifteen thousand
dollars and here's what I can pay over
the next 12 months 15 months 24 months
and you make the payment don't hand her
any more money yes okay so directly to
the if I if I buy give a direct
direct my information no it doesn't
matter just get the login and pay it say
Mom the only way you're getting this
money is I sit right next to you we log
in and we pay it because you're not
handing her you're not funding her uh
ridiculousness
because she has not been a good Steward
with money so that is Ridiculousness and
you're not gonna hand her fifteen
thousand dollars to do whatever it is
that she's been doing which whatever
that was caused a student loan to Triple
all right so we're not participating in
that yeah really bad okay so here's
another thing we're going to do Sarah
I'm gonna give you
I'm going to give you
um a year of
FPU okay
and she might not but she's still got 55
000 left to pay off after you write her
check
and so if she wants to you can sit down
and put these videos on and y'all can
come up with a plan it's not too late
for her either we deal with folks all
the time in the 50s 60s who are figuring
it out and it's not too late but you get
to make that choice she gets to make
that choice okay so hang on the line
here we're gonna hook you up
um and hope and maybe even say I'm Gonna
Give You fifteen thousand dollars which
is five grand more but you got to sit
down and watch these videos with me
because you got 55 000 and listen if she
starts hassling you start saying oh
you're just gonna leave your mama to
what you can always stand up and walk
out the door and that's hard hard hard
but remember this line behavior is a
language
and if your mom chooses to swear at you
get mad at you send you on guilt trips
that you can't afford
she's telling you through her language I
don't want you around here
I don't value you and so I'm gonna hear
what you're saying through your actions
and I'm gonna head out the door until we
can have a grown-up conversation it's
going to be hard hard treading um you
have to grieve the loss of your mom or
your new relationship with your mom
because things are different now dude
money does weird things to people John
but this is why I mean I can't
money money makes people act up though
like it does but but co-signing on loans
man just I I've never seen it work well
it doesn't work I haven't seen it work
well it doesn't work co-signing is is
stupid and especially if you have listen
if you've taken a loan out with your
kids and you all have like car payment
you just pay me back or you go no no no
no put it in a spreadsheet be adults and
say you owe me this much on this date in
this way and and and think about this
she said she was 17 when her mom signed
that loan adults be adults and
understand that your kids were kids and
you were adulting them at that time do
not come after these folks for these
Parent Plus Loans you you signed them
parents Parent PLUS that means parent
plus your money the the best who's
paying the bank looked at your kid and
said I'm not giving him money and you
said well you can give it to me I'm
trustworthy yeah be trustworthy be
trustworthy be trustworthy
and pay pay your bills parents act like
parents parents act like parents